[Music]
hello my name is Franz timmermans
I'm vice president of the European
Commission and I have a huge task in the
next five years that is to make sure
that Europe has an answer to the climate
crisis we need to stick together as
Europeans to come up with solutions for
the rise and temperature we need to make
sure that in the next thirty years the
temperature doesn't rise about above 1.5
degrees and to do that we need to make
our continent and the world climate
neutral in this Europe can lead we can
show that between now and 2050 we can
reduce our emissions to zero this will
lead to a planet that can carry humanity
and this will lead to a society where in
a fair way we can share the burden of
doing this and Europe should take the
lead because countries individually are
just too small and if Europe takes the
lead I'm quite sure the rest of the
world will follow